defeat it's a government defeat let's
see the numbers the eyes to the right
308 the nose to the left
the eyes to the right 308 the nose to
the left
322 so the noes have it the noes have it
unlock well a government defeat there by
a majority of 14 Jeremy Corbyn on his
feet the Prime Minister's deal tonight
the houses
[Applause]
you too hasty I'm not finished yet
tonight the house has refused to be
bounced into debating a hugely
significant piece of legislation in just
two days with barely any notice and an
analysis of the economic impact of this
bill the Prime Minister is the author of
his own misfortune so I make this offer
to him tonight work with us work with us
all of us to agree a reasonable
timetable and I suspect this house will
vote to debate scrutinize and I hope
amend the detail of this bill that would
be the sensible way forward and that's
the offer I make on behalf of the
opposition tonight
[Music]
[Applause]